il a 19 ans et déjà neuf matches de top
14 jouée cette saison arrière polyvalent
léobard et couvre plusieurs postes au
stade français paris demi d'ouverture
trois quarts centre ou arrière issus du
club de versailles il poursuit sa
progression avec l'équipe
professionnelle parisienne énormément
minutes de jeu puis surtout une
continuité certes j'ai réussi à
enchaîner cinq matches d'affilée à
chaque fois après il me laisser au repos
24 et c'était plutôt c'était plutôt
intéressant pour moi d'évoluer avec les
banques parmi ces prestations cette
saison une rencontre à perpignan
le jeune joueur du stade français c'est
être décisif pour son équipe sur une
pénalité il a inscrit les trois points
de la victoire
hors frais quand j'ai regardé le match
beaucoup d'ambiance mais à aimé giral
mais pour le match et ben on est dans
notre bulle donc ça ça a beaucoup joué
et est arrivé au stade français paris à
l'été 2000 20 mai au bar et a prolongé
son contrat dans le club parisien
jusqu'en 2025 une satisfaction pour le
manager de l'équipe gonzalo quesada
beaucoup de talent mais aussi beaucoup
de qualités de travail il ya encore du
travail pour lui pour être un grand
joueur installé au moins en top 14 il
fait partie de ceux qui ont
l'intelligence et d'humilité de la
lucidité des des savoirs qui a un
parcours encore encore devant nous à
faire mais c'est sûr que c'est un des
rares joueurs qui aujourd'hui on
il a 19 ans et on oublie qu'on nous dit
qu'à 19 ans leo barré joue aussi en
équipe de france moins de 20 ans avec
quatre sélections à son compteur il
participera début janvier à un stage de
préparation en vue du tournoi des six
nations 2022
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]